thanks Maria I am very happy to be here
and be able to talk to you for a few
moments about none focus and hopefully
you will be able to have a better
understanding of the work we're doing to
support this incredible community I'm
Leah cilan I'm the executive director of
known focus and I am very humbled to be
able to work with the incredible people
behind the projects and in this
community that I have grown too grown to
love over the last four and a half years
none focus was started by a group of
individuals who like any wonderful thing
that is coming to be started in
discussion at conferences and also of
our mailing list so I'm at in 2010 the
open source scientific community had
reached a critical point they were in
need of a more formal structure to help
support the projects and to also help
organize the community there was at that
time in 2011 Fernando Perez gave a
keynote at a euro CyHi event and he
explained that the entire Python
scientific stack at that point was
essentially relying on the free work of
30 individuals and at the same time
there was no funding and the projects
were being used at that time by you know
definitely on the academic level but
also by beginning to be used by industry
at a greater rate each and every day so
this this was a critical time what you
know what were they going to do so on
that mailing list and in those
discussions it was decided that nut
focus would be created they were trying
to figure out what name to call it and I
think Anthony scope ATS actually was the
one that came up is that correct with
was one of the ones that had was had
input on the the name for the
organization
so by 2011 the end of 2011 a board was
put together and these are the founding
board members Travis elephant who was
the author of numpy and the founding
contributor to the syfy package Fernando
Perez ipython at the time Jupiter was in
its infancy or perhaps not even born it
at that point John Hunter matplotlib
Perry greenfield at the Space Telescope
Science Institute who was a key key
figure in numerous projects at the time
Jared Millman who was working at
Berkeley with Fernando and Anthony's go
pats who just heard from who is at
university of chicago at that time I had
the distinct pleasure of being
introduced to this community and being
interviewed by Travis John and Perry and
it was a I think at the time I would
have been a little bit more humbled or
maybe more nervous at that interview
process if I had known the impact on so
many that that these individuals had
created and were responsible for so the
vision the original vision was to
support the open source scientific
computing and how how was that going to
be done what what was needed so over the
the next year there were many
discussions on that how to best meet the
needs of the product of the projects and
funding was a huge concern ipython at
the time was needing to go after was
wanting to apply for some grants and had
the possibility of Microsoft providing
some funding for them and their this was
a project I mean this was a problem for
the projects how how was this funding
going to happen how is it going to what
if what if the projects were given a
grant you know Fernando could not put
this in his personal bank account
there there was no legal entity to be
able to not only take in that money to
be also but to also guarantee that the
money was going to be spent in a way
that that followed the mission of them
focus but also the mission that it would
it would support the project so at that
point to 2014 ipython came on is the
first fiscally sponsored project of an
unfocused so the fiscal sponsorship
program was was born um it there was a
lot of discussion on the best way to set
this up and how it could best serve
Fleur of the projects by the end of 2014
5 additional projects had come on board
and as you can see this is these are not
all based on Python from the very
beginning the founding board members
wanted to make sure that this would be
open source scientific computing it
would not just represent the Python
tools but it would be open to open to
all tools as of today we have 18 and I
think we're you're missing one logo
waiting for one more of fiscal
sponsorship agreement to be signed 18
projects that we now physically sponsor
and our fiscal sponsorship besides just
being a legal entity we handle all the
financial admin that these projects need
and you would think that might not be a
lot but let me tell you it it is a lot
of work our staff is very very busy
trying to keep up with the the need that
this creates handling accounts invoicing
making sure anytime there's a hackathon
anytime projects are getting together
making sure all that's coordinated
trying to work on sustainability for the
projects making sure it research has
kept reproducible there's a lot of work
that goes into this and I I'm just
thrilled that we have so many wonderful
projects under our umbrella at this time
so at the same time our fiscal
sponsorship program was being worked on
there was also the issue of not only
supporting the projects but supporting
the community so there was a little
organization our conference that was
formed called PI data first of all I'm
Travis elefante Peter Wang and Julie
steel organized a workshop for 40 people
that took place at in Mountain View at
Google and they got to go together
talked about the Python scientific stack
and what the needs were at that time
continuum because at the same time
Travis and Peter were had founded
continuum analytics decided that they
would continue this on the larger scale
and had event at our first event in New
York late 2012 and I was because
continuum had donated office space for
none Focus which at that time was just
myself I helped out with that event and
during the event seeing the community
that it brought together it was decided
that PI data should become a nun focus
event and from then on it's what you see
today has happened we've had PI data
events in 13 cities this event today is
our 24th event and three and a half
years so we've been very busy it has
created a incredible community that has
supported the project through educating
being able people to share knowledge
about how the projects are being used
but perhaps just as importantly creating
a network where people can reach out to
each other share their knowledge be able
to exchange how the projects are being
used both in the academic realm and also
for industry so it's created a huge
impact and we are very like I said
humbled to be part of this and to be
able to facilitate local organizations
such as the one here in Durham that is
actually created these events around the
world
so going back quickly to that original
original focus of focus of an unfocused
excuse the pun there the project's
supporting the projects was was kind of
half of what we wanted to do and that
again is supported through fiscal
sponsorship through small grants that no
focus is to be able to give through
domain and trademark ownership it's
really important that there is not an
individual that owns the domains and
trademarks for for the projects and also
through sustainability efforts we're
launching a large sustainability effort
that we have through a sloan grant that
we were granted and we are very excited
to be able to launch that next year that
will initially support our fiscally
sponsored projects but then hopefully be
able to be extended to all open source
projects so the other half of this is
the community support and that's what
we're doing that's what we're doing
today through PI data through other
workshops and events a lot of many of
these so much of the support of the
community is there are educational
programs so the conference and workshops
are John Hunter technical fellowship and
diversity initiatives we have quite a
few diversity initiatives please come to
our go to our website and learn more
about those we have a diversity and
scientific computing mailing list that
we invite you all to join and be able to
use that for for communication and last
but not least please go to none focus
org check out our membership we have
free community membership anyone can
join receive our newsletter get project
updates on what's going on with the with
the community with PI data and we also
invite you to check out our supporting
membership which you may do so at any
any level and everything is appreciated
so hopefully you have a little better
understanding of what we do and we
invite you to be a part of it thank you
you